أنا سعيد جدًا بذلك على الرغم من كل شيء
عقبات أمام كل عقبات ما
تلك الحكاية فقط أن الصيرورة لم تحاول
على النزيف ما زلنا نطلق و
فتح آرتي في الألمانية الآن
انها الألمانية هي عطلة عظيمة
بالنسبة لنا لجميع الرجال الذين
عملت عليها وهي صعبة للغاية
هذه المرة لم نفتح القناة بعد
أبدا vaper لأننا ضربنا أكثر
الوباء ثانيًا لأننا
لدهشة كبيرة ، ألمانيا
كانت ألمانيا الأكثر تعصبًا
البلد لنشر المعلومات
حرية المعلومات إلى حرية التعبير
لأنهم قاتلوا معنا و
تواصل القتال في ألمانيا معنا لا
قاتلوا ولم يضربوا في أي شيء آخر
دولة من العالم في أكثر من قارة واحدة
الجانب الآخر ألمانيا العامة الألمانية
بدا الجمهور جدا
مهتم بمعلوماتنا
المعلومات التي لم تعد
لن يقرأ ولا يسمع في أي مكان
ممتن جدًا لما تقوله هذه الأرقام
القاعة التي تمكنا من تحقيقها
لم تطلق القناة على هذا النحو
ديفيد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أنظمة مختلفة على الموقع
ينشر الخبر كما أتمنى
إطلاق القناة التليفزيونية جمهورنا سيكون
ابتهج معنا أكثر
هذا الحدث نفسه ، وسنفعل كل شيء
لجمهورنا باللغة الألمانية
اللغة لا تخيب
[موسيقى]
ويعطي
نظرة صادقة على
الأحداث الدولية و
شرح موقف روسيا بشكل مهم
موقف الروس من مختلف القضايا
ضرورة مطلقة ، ليس فقط
من باب الاهتمام ولكن أيضًا لمستقبل العالم
الأمان
[موسيقى]